avec vous une rifaï bien sûr bon jolin
aujourd'hui la crise du crédit yen ne
fait pas seulement plonger les bourses
mondiales on a parlé encore hier avec
christophe dans cette elle fait aussi
flamber les prix de l'or noir le prix du
baril de pétrole se rapproche
dangereusement partant de la barre des
100 dollars c'est vrai paul est une
semaine après semaine les prix de l'or
noir continue de progresser ils
rejoignent les sommet qu'il avait
atteint en 2014 il ya eu huit ans alors
ce matin le baril de brent qui est
utilisé comme référence en europe et
bien le baril de 20 qu'il frôlait 96
dollars on est donc un plus haut niveau
depuis septembre 2014 c'est une
progression qui est à signer tout voyez
ici la progression au cours des 12
derniers mois on est sur une progression
de près de 50 % sur un an et si on
regarde depuis le début de l'année une
progression de près de 20% alors
pourquoi les prix flambent s'il est bien
parce que les acteurs du marché
craignent donc c'est un conflit entre la
russie et l'ukraine ce qui explique donc
la hausse de ces derniers jours être ces
dernières semaines pourquoi aussi parce
que la russie donc est un poids lourd du
pétrole au niveau mondial c'est le
deuxième exportateur mondial le
troisième producteur mondial derrière
les etats-unis et l'arabie saoudite et
la production russe ses 11 % de la
production mondiale près de 11 millions
de barils par jour une grande partie va
vers les pays européens d'ailleurs 4
million sont exportés vers l'union
européenne 4 millions de barils par jour
est donc concrètement pourquoi peut-on
avoir un impact donc s'il ya un conflit
entre l'ukraine et la russie sur les
marchés donc pétrolier parce que l'offre
de pétrole russe pourrait diminuer cela
par exemple à cause d' attaques sur des
oléoducs ou encore si des sanctions
venait à toucher donc le secteur
pétrolier russe mais la crise on en
ukraine n'est pas la seule explication à
cette hausse des prix non c'est ce qui
explique en effet la hausse de ces
derniers jours voire de ces dernières
semaines mais la hausse est plus globale
ça fait des mois que les prix du pétrole
augmente et cela s'explique notamment
par le contexte économique mondial la
reprise économique post confinement qui
a un impact sur la demande une demande
de pétrole qui augmente très rapidement
alors que l'offre elle ne suit pas il ya
un décalage entre l'offre et la demande
qui est estimé autour de 2 millions de
barils par jour selon l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie alors
l'offre elle augmente aussi moins vite
de la part des pays de l'opep et de
leurs alliés donc au sein de l'opep plus
une production qui augmente certes donc
mais pas assez vite pour répondre à la
demande et puis les stocks qui sont
aussi en baisse dans ce contexte là à
cela s'ajoutent aussi des
investissements qui n'ont pas assez
augmentée qui ont même baissé au cours
des dernières années au cours des cinq
dernières années écoutez les
explications de cet analyste au micro de
nos confrères de france 2
la volonté de faire une transition
énergétique et de sortir des produits
pétroliers des investisseurs et les
compagnies pétrolières ont très bien
compris et ont décidé de réduire leurs
investissements dans les nouvelles
explorations donc pour les trois à
quatre prochaines années on risque de
connaître une période très difficile en
termes de disponibilité pétrolière alors
voilà pour les explications les
conséquences et bien tout le monde les
ressent au moment d'aller faire le plein
à la station service et c'est notamment
le cas ici en france on en parle
beaucoup puisque la hausse des prix du
carburant elle n'a pas sûr pouvoir
d'achat le pouvoir d'achat qui est la
principale préoccupation des français à
quelques semaines donc du scrutin les
prix du carburant ou d'ailleurs atteint
des records la semaine dernière dans le
sillage de la flambée donc des cours du
brut selon les dernières données
publiées lundi par le ministère de la
transition écologique je vous propose
d'écouter d'ailleurs les réactions de
ses consommateurs c'est en fait
psychologiquement on se dit on va
atteindre la barre des 2 euros voilà
c'est à ça qu'on pense on se dit qu'on
va pas pouvoir durer longtemps comme ça
en fait
ça encourage de télétravail cela dit
parce que effectivement ça on essaie de
limiter au maximum de déplacement et
dans ce contexte la police il ya eu des
mesures d'accompagnement de la part du
gouvernement d'abord comme
l'augmentation de l'indemnité
kilométrique l'indemnité inflation et
aussi des mesures mises en place par les
distributeurs comme des ristournes des
promotions sur le carburant oui vous
parlez de l'inflation à la hausse des
prix du carburant de l'énergie en
général ça fait gonfler l'inflation oui
on voit ça aux états unis on voit ça
aussi en zone euro l'inflation bat des
records jamais vu depuis la création de
l'union monétaire est ce qui explique
cette inflation c'est d'abord la hausse
des prix de l'énergie regardez 28,6 pour
cent d'augmentation des prix de
l'énergie en janvier 2022 par rapport à
la même période il y a un an donc cela
alimente l'inflation et même la
présidente de la banque centrale
européenne christine lagarde a reconnu
que l'inflation allait rester forte un
certain moment plus longtemps que prévu
en tout cas ne devrait baisser que dans
le courant de cette année un peu plus
tard et il va y avoir évidemment des
conséquences sur la politique monétaire
probablement des hausses de taux qui
vont venir plus tôt que prévu on verra
cela en tout cas au cours de la
prochaine réunion de la banque centrale
européenne prévue en mars merci beaucoup
lina tout à l'heure dans paraît direct
on verra si les marchés européens vont
mieux ce matin que ses jours